plus de vingt ans que jean claude
montluc élèves sur ses quatre hectares
de terres ou diamant ce déport semi
liberté un gage de qualité et de
bien-être pour l'animal par rapport à
l'élevage en bâtiment sens à mes
libertés on n'a pas de soins continuer à
faire parce que les bêtes ne sont pas
malades souvent on n'a pas
d'antibiotiques a donné on n'a pas de
sous et comme les porcelets par exemple
on n'a pas de sens
j'ai la chance aujourd'hui d'avoir un
seul qui n'a pas de crocs des
conseillers nature n'a pas eu de cannes
de banal et ça m'a fermé
tout d'abord une assurance parce qu
amateur elle est saine bonjour madame
mélissa syrie les techniciennes
d'encadrement à la coopérative porcine
de la martinique
son rôle est de conseiller de guider
l'éleveur dans ses choix et dans
l'organisation de son exploitation
sur le plan sanitaire alimentaire ou
encore génétique est pour elle un
élevage en semi liberté comme celui ci
comporte un certain nombre davantage aux
l'animal même le fait d'être conduits en
liberté il est libre donc il va pouvoir
refaire le nombre de pas qui veut durant
sa journée il va fouiller le sol pour
essayer d'aller chercher tous les atouts
les apports naturels qui peut trouver
dans le sol il épouse les failles et les
mieux du coup ça va ça va lui donner
une vienne qui sera un petit peu moins
stressés et donc une viande qui sera la
plus goûteuse
si les cochons reçoivent quelques
gâteries comme ce corner de glace ce
n'est pas la base de leur alimentation
qui est plutôt varié
on a de la famille mais les forains
salling été souvent nous avons un mixage
de nourriture à faire jusqu'à jean la
banane j'ai je pense de la banane je
prends des légumes parce que parfois
j'ai des restes de légumes ont fait des
légumes et en j'ai du pain si vous vous
posez la question entre cochons plancher
pas en créole il n'y a pas de différence
c'est seulement le nom qui a changé en
fait l'animal est rapidement
reconnaissable de lot de petites
bouclettes et aussi sur les pâtes bio
qui sont des pieds plats et puis là
robes noires ou d'acheter on a des métis
et des dominos